to the house and go and rest my spirit
back welcome back to throwing chairs
I said throwing chess not spinet god
dammit my life is so horrible
anyway as we left up we found a security
card that says it goes on the first
floor so I guess I guess we're going out
the first floor I don't that's the
elevator
alright we're doing with it sorry sorry
sorry I just can't help but dancing when
I hear elevator music
that's a nightmare this game is truly a
horror game guys we have to continue
playing you [ __ ] owe your nut bounce
well I guess technically you're related
what is this huh I didn't use it up whoa
this place is huge
Paulo voodoo are you [ __ ] serious you
cherish buddy I'm sure people try to
work Jesus Christ
I am so upset you are going to the fan
that's not a fan Pierce well no one
gives a [ __ ] two new messages well you
better tell them to me right now done
holy [ __ ]
on a stick why would you put [ __ ] on a
stick in it god damn it what about this
[ __ ] of course
[ __ ] genius I am the smartest mother
you better open yeah this traitor
you [ __ ] barrels look what your dad
[ __ ] on his face oh god damn it I can't
go that coming I should find a way
through this gas well Yolo it's [ __ ]
what are you what are you I'm trying to
hide [ __ ] from a girl we have this
flashlight now by the way hello
don't do that again no no what do you
want from me
stay the hell away uh Can I grab him now
I can grab the bench
a man does not have nipples or himself
what about you so Jack cold right my
clothes please could you go search that
they should be somewhere around the
hospital
I'll get your reward be able to find
them what reward why are you in that
post why you naked I now find your
clothes I know what it's like I know
what it's like to be naked
am i stealing frame I don't [ __ ] know
locked I know that game I know that I
like how he censored his penis that's
wonderful
I can't have penises in a game all right
what have we got
maybe he will wear this saw maybe not
how about this what I have a hammer
what is up with this [ __ ] sound okay
you know you know I don't appreciate
this know I don't know my dog what is
going on here no we're just gonna go in
here your daddy - going down I tell you
nice to see you again well it's not nice
to see you
you have very ugly legs you go since you
were gone for almost a year now
everything changed what changed you're
the one responsible for all this this
Brian
he's a [ __ ] that day that day
changed me and I saw it changed you as
well probably for the better
let's be honest - go now good zoom in
very closely is it alcohol I will see
you soon Jase god damn it I don't want
no promises from that okay well fine
we're going over here
scheisse what is in here hello
Pence's not approve this goddamn it's
like an endless safe station okay
we're pushing forward res type rider
walking pipe rider I know this shirts
Hey well I saw you naked and that was a
lot worse long well you're coming with
me that he'll leave nothing about it hey
I'll leave you there I'll come back for
you don't worry about this mod is
[ __ ] creepy man I did not expect this
I am NOT okay with this
No thank you sir where's the naked man I
never thought I said that white wasn't
it in here oh there you are man you know
how much [ __ ] I went for your [ __ ]
clothes a t-shirt Thanks
finally some warmth I know another way
Jay did not want to get enough for this
take this key card I found it in the
basement area
just do me a favor though take care of
yourself I have seen things don't bother
my things things I almost have seen it
just please be careful okay
all right where does this go ground
floor to the ground flow pros
maybe not so soon damn it is right there
should I run for it don't you dare tell
them yay hide the music girls I got a
pee really bad
alright hey chance how you say day sorry
- it's okay I know it's not your fault
okay ground floor I think I know where
it is
can I come parents oh it's right here oh
okay can't you forgot about Mike what
what did someone say something
okay on second thought I might bring the
chair crazy you go first
I have us protection goddamn it Pierce
you just want to be fine
go okay looks like we're fine okay one
step at a time
we don't want to [ __ ] up and I in this
hellhole ah oh no we lost chair it's
okay I have nothing I don't like this
faceless I don't know about your breast
not a big whoa what the [ __ ] do not
teleport integers what are you doing not
cool man
but it says no power well at least a
chairman is gone get it
chairman haha thank you what I'm doing
here
I guess I gotta get the power back but
how does one get the power back
okay well that's it's funny give him a
hug I don't think my has a go what about
him here no I says gasoline whoa whoa
whoa calm down sorry sorry should
probably not have that next to the
gasoline
okay I have a flash camera flash this
lamp looks suspicious oh my god
we got the power back okay good I don't
need you anymore
Oh what the [ __ ] what happened what
about you what do you know well you
better I am a pretty good hider
that barrels yeah dad they follow me
everywhere
I sure as hell not going down there I
shut up
sorry talk all you want alright I'm
going down yo
alright breasts gonna end this episode
here but I hope you enjoyed watching
maybe like if you did hit subscribe to
come for a day I'll see you the next one